if you can only remember two words
two words i'm going to give you the
whole tweet storm in two words now if
you were paying attention and these are
very important both words are loaded and
because i have to compress them down to
two words you have to get it precisely
but anytime you are trying to figure out
what to do
think of these two words
productize
yourself
okay so basically not product of
yourself productize yourself what you're
going to do is you're going to create a
product
out of whatever it is that you naturally
and uniquely do really really well
okay
of course you have to read the
tweetstorm to understand what those two
words mean to get a lot of concept
context but just those two you can carry
those in your heads productize yourself
you're building a product that product
is a set of things that you uniquely
know how to do that hopefully society
wants that you can leverage and scale up
but products by their nature are
leveraged products by their nature are
scaled up and yourself means that you
don't get to compete at being somebody
else because if you compete at being
somebody else you're not going to be the
best in the world at it and if you're
not the best in the world at it you will
not get rewarded properly for it so yes
it's how you package yourself in a
product
so
you know this is it's hard this is why i
say it takes decades not just because it
just takes decades to execute but the
better part of a decade may just be
just may just be used figuring out what
it is that you can uniquely provide i i
sort of have a
i have a single e-day fix that i'm
completely obsessed with in um
on on the business side which is that uh
if you're starting a company if you're
the founder entrepreneur starting a
company you always want to aim for
monopoly and um and that uh and you want
to always avoid competition and so uh
hence uh competition is for losers uh
something we'll be talking about today
i'd like to um
i'd like to start by saying something
about
um
the the basic idea of uh when you start
one of these companies um how you go
about uh creating value and there's this
question what makes a business valuable
and i want to suggest that there's
basically a very simple uh very simple
formula that um
you you have a valuable company if two
things are true
number one that it creates x dollars of
value for the world and number two that
you capture y percent of x
and and the critical thing that uh that
i think people
always miss in the sort of analysis is
that x and y are completely independent
variables and so
x can be very big y can be very small
x can be of intermediate size and if y
is reasonably big you can still get a
very big business so to create a
valuable company you have to basically
both create something of value and
capture some fraction of the value of
what you've created
and sort of just to
just to illustrate this is a as a
contrast um
there's
if you sort of compare the u.s airline
industry with a company like google on
search
uh if you sort of measure by
the size of these industries you could
you could say that airlines are still
more important than search if you just
measure it say by revenues there's 195
billion in uh domestic revenues in 2000
2012. google had uh just north of 50
billion um and and so and certainly sort
of on some intuitive level if you said
uh if you were given a choice and said
well do you want to get rid of all air
travel or do you want to get rid of your
ability to use search engines the
intuition would be that air travel is
something that's more important than
search and this is of course just the
domestic numbers if you looked at this
globally um airlines are much much
bigger than um than uh than than than
searcher than google is but uh but the
profit margins are quite a bit less uh
you know they were marginally profitable
in 2012. um i think the entire hundred
year history of the airline industry the
cumulative profits in the us have been
approximately zero now companies make
money they episodically go bankrupt they
get recapitalized and you sort of cycle
and repeat
and this is reflected in you know the
the combined market capitalization of
the of the airline industries maybe uh
something um of the us airline industry
something like a quarter that of google
so so uh you have you have a search
engine much much smaller than air travel
but much more valuable and i think this
this reflects these very different uh
valuations on x and y yo what's up gary
how are you
i'm good um quite brief i want to
document
not cr uh create create yeah yeah that's
the one
the thing is i've got so many things i
want to talk about man how wide or
narrow do i go with my focus today why
is humanly possible
yeah and why would that be because it's
better
so okay
all right because the reality is you
have no idea what anybody wants to hear
from you yet yeah
so what are you going to arbitrarily
pick
there's literally no downside
yeah that's why
and would you give an amount of time
before you know if something's working
or not yes how long
years
so a handful things at once okay maybe
wider the number one advantage you have
is the potpourri of your different
interests
it's interesting i like it you know the
fact that i garage sales sports cards
wine
business that's what makes me different
and some people don't want that content
and i'm sure when somebody goes through
my instagram and sees to this is a post
around garage sailing and they're there
for social media tactics they just skip
through it
i'm not charging them
it only cost them a hundredth of a
[ __ ] second yeah
do you understand yeah i understand good
thanks man you got it
[Applause]
i think people underestimate maybe how
valuable their specific knowledge is or
how unique they are um
that's something that is kind of
we all have you know self-doubts and
insecurities and we are like you know
we're used to walking down the street
and feeling not too dissimilar from ten
thousand other people that we study
these success stories and it feels so
maybe far away and like those people
were so different than us um but it's
not like i think everyone has something
really valuable to bring and can
productize themselves in an interesting
way and everyone's
story can be
valuable to someone um anything
is a hell of a drug yeah
it's a hell of a drug and i would say
like
no matter how small you start like jack
again has an amazing cure for this his
goal is just like make one dollar on the
internet just go sell one thing to one
person for one dollar and you will feel
different it will start that snowball
and you kind of slowly build up the
confidence you know you got to start at
the tutorial level maybe
but you're going to keep building that
confidence and you're going to slowly
kind of
grow your way into finding your audience
and find your way through that maze and
just taking that first step will give
you the confidence to take the second to
take the third um
but but you you know whoever is
listening to this you are more unique
and valuable than you think you are
and everyone is kind of an incredible
combination of their genetics and their
experience and their perspectives and
their beliefs and everyone is unique and
everyone has
some sort of skill or insight that they
can bring to other people if you can
learn it and package it the right way
and just
see what people respond to that you want
to bring to them um
so that's
you know that's probably even before the
kind of
logistical stumbling blocks is just the
belief that there's something there for
you to do and for you to add value
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you